tens of thousands of people took to the
streets of West Hollywood yesterday for
the yearly celebration of pride
this year rebranded as they resist March
for lgbtq+ equality now we frequently
take shots in Los Angeles on this
program because you know la is kind of a
toilet a lot of the time but you have to
say Angelenos can be very inspiring when
they want to be I mean this is
incredibly impressive that so many
people can mobilize for a cause
especially considering how much
marijuana is everywhere all the time so
it's beautiful what wonderful scent
wonderful wonderful March people kept
taking photos and of this marches on
official mascot I don't know if you know
this the babadook well and this is this
is the dapper monster from the 2014
indie horror hit that has been an
inadvertent gay icon his movie was
mistakenly listed on Netflix as an LGBT
movie it's not really at all anyway so
now he's an icon this marcher has a sign
that put it best I may wear a top hat
but I'm a pure bottom baby this comedian
the distress of Monsters inspiring
politics continues what is another
monster a little full can you see a
political rally Kurt Braunohler
ah what do we want rain when do we want
it bring very good points to Ray Romano
ah I want to suck your blood and have
universal health care pay for it all
right boy yep Kamel no Johnny God made
Adam and Steve not Freddy vs. Jason all
right boy